this is the goal now to bring impact to
the western world to bring solutions
that are better than the solution that
we have today more environmental
friendly and more economical
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures
j ventures riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders i am with
oshik efrati the ceo co-founder and
board member at home biogas
or she graduated with a bachelor's of
science degree in marine sciences
specializing in water treatment while
she cleared the product development team
at shelves israel's largest tactical
gear manufacturer and exporter where he
launched an innovative product sold on a
global scale his next entrepreneurial
endeavor was founding home biogas
together with his co-founders
and eres lanza in 2012.
thank you very much for being here oshik
you're working on some really exciting
things and i'm looking forward to
picking your brain in these 20 minutes
as to why you are so excited about them
and with home biogas looking at waste
looking at renewable energy
a really fascinating topic that that has
been emerging over the last really
recent years and looking more critically
at the world and the way that we manage
our waste so i have to understand first
from you oshik what do you really care
about you know what is this
whole thing about for you
so
it's a big question but uh
start with the started with the product
we want to turn waste into something
with value and actually if you look on
live so
it's a good thing to do to to take
something
problematic and to turn it into
something valuable
so this is what we are doing with our
product we are creating solution to
treat organic waste which is a big
problem and turning it into renewable
energy
which is great solutions so we take a
problem and turn it into a solution
and then
what what what what else what did you
ask more than uh then then
what would you like to know
well where where is this where does this
meet you i mean looking at waste
renewable solutions looking at the world
i mean why do you care about this so
much i mean everybody cares about you
know waste management and everybody
conceptually cares about renewable
energy but why are you dedicating your
life right now to solving this problem
yes okay so
interesting question um
actually
before home biogas i
i found myself inventing products some
of them were really successful in the
market
some of the product got to a stage of
some of the product i developed got to a
stage of mass production
and i i understood the effect
of
success when you succeed
when you succeed in doing something that
go into the masses
actually create a lot of waste
and uh
10 years ago
when i decided to go to the next
project
i looked for a project that is actually
and not only
will be success economic economically
but i also wanted to make something that
will do good
good to humans go to the environment
i wanted to create
to either to to create a product that
will actually
make an impact
um
and once i found it
the the effect of it is
is actually amazing it gives you huge
motivation
um
it gives
a lot of reason to wake up in the
morning and to push
the whole industry
a hundred years old the industry of
waste management disrupted
made new solutions a lot of money saved
a lot of pollution improve people's
lives and
and actually make a positive impact on
the world
so before we get into more concretely
the the problem that you're solving and
the way that you're creatively solving
it with home bio gas
as as an entrepreneur and sort of as a
leader in this endeavor do you have some
so you know some set kpis in your mind
or some set you know matrix that will
define success for you
in other words what is sort of the the
big
goal here of home biogas you're
mentioning making an impact it's not
just economically
what is sort of the north star that
you're aligning yourself in your
organization to
yeah so definitely i have kpis i have
dreams i have goals and it's evolving
as the company grows the the dreams and
the goals are also
growing up
at the beginning
the early stage of the company the goal
was to bring solutions
to developing countries to africa
southeast asia
three billion people that don't have
access to
to cooking to clean cooking gas they
they are still using
fire cook
suffer from indo air pollution
breeding the smoke so at the beginning
it was the goal was to make it
affordable to make biobars affordable
and available to those people
now after 10 years i feel that we
actually accomplish goal
and now we have new dreams
now we want to create students
to talk to people
like
to people in in western countries in
developed countries
the us
to bring solutions for restaurants
hotels
multi-family houses groundhouses
we are adjusting all the products to
more advanced
advanced technology that will be
a a market fit to to
to the us for example
so this is the goal now to bring impact
to the western world to to bring
solutions
that are better than the solution that
we have today more environmental
friendly and more economical
so okay so we have to go back and lay
the groundwork for all of us to
understand so
looking at waste management and energy
what is in effect the problem that
you're mentioning a century-old problem
much more than that probably well what
is the problem that you're setting out
to solve and and where is the home
biogas
positioning itself within the solution
space
right
so
today actually a
there is a huge problem on a climate
change as as we all know and the one of
the causes of climate change is the
greenhouse gases
the worm is getting hotter
and one of the major source of
greenhouse gases is methane gas
methane gas ch4
is produced by waste
actually more than 50 of the methane gas
which is a very strong greenhouse gas
produced by organic waste
now most of the ways today ends up in
landfills which it's actually a hole in
the ground
and the transportation of waste is also
a very primitive
a a
all the transportation and the land
filling is a very pollutive
process and it's also very expensive
and what we are doing is uh we are
actually creating systems that are like
trash cans
that you throw the organic waste into it
but instead of collecting it it's just
treating the waste on site
by biological process and turn it into
energy that you can use on site
and with this solution we are working
with
families for example in kenya in africa
families in mexico in brazil
but we also working with thousands of
families already in the us in australia
in
europe um
so this is what we do
and then so more tangibly what what is
the what is the home biogas as a product
what does the company actually do
the company what we are doing is first
we are
developing the product
which is a very
innovative
process
the
all
all the process from the beginning till
the end we are developing it here
transform it from development stage to
manufacturing stage and then we market
the product
uh
we have
a chain of a distributor we have 20
countries that we already have
distributors that are working locally
some of the countries like kenya we are
working ourselves
in front of the people
and we are creating awareness with the
people and then sell the product give
after sell support we are doing their
own cycle
and we also have projects with the
international organizations
we just finished
a project two projects with the u.n one
in malawi one in zimbabwe
a we installed burger system to treat
the organic waste of
a refugee camps in malawi and zimbabwe
and turned into local energy
so so really pay me a picture of what
this product is because
for those that aren't going to the
website and seeing it in person this is
a physical product that people actually
interact with in the day to day so what
you know really you know trend and
describe to me how does this look what
does it actually do and what is sort of
the consumer experience that a person
who uses home biogas's product what do
they actually have to do to turn their
waste into renewable energy
right so i'll tell you about my my
family my house
in my we i have two kids and a beautiful
wife
and
we have
food left over after you know every
every day we are ending up with the
something like three four meters of a
a
vegetables meat dairy product
so we are segregating the organic waste
we have a different trash can for that
one small one and then at the end of the
day i'm taking this trash can the
organic
the organic arm
where i'm going out and and then in the
garden i have a burger system it's same
it's like in the size of a
of saying a young
big trash can and i'm throwing the waste
into it
the waste goes down to an a anaerobic
digester that in this digester there are
bacteria that decompose the waste
and break it down
and produce
biogas burgers made out of
mostly from methane gas the system know
how to clean the gas collect it
and eventually deliver it back to the
kitchen
and actually we are cooking on burgers
for the last eight years
all our meals we are cooking on burgers
that is
the system also creates liquid
fertilizer wow and the liquid fertilizer
and so is connected to my garden
through an irrigation system
and it's amazing what it's doing to the
plants it's uh it's really amazing
so literally you're taking the existing
waste that you're producing you're
turning it into energy that is enough to
allow you to cook your next meals which
then creates a cycle that you're
basically self-sustaining plus you're
getting this fertilizer so you're
actually even getting a net positive
from this whole process
now
what's in it for the average consumer so
in other words it's it's great for it
sounds amazing for people that are very
proactive and and care but how do we get
this so that every house in the world
uses this product either and i'm curious
both by the way from a a behavioral
perspective so how do we actually get
people to choose to
to intentionally spend more minutes of
the day
doing this but also on on you know cost
efficiency going ahead and purchasing
something like this how does it actually
work
so we have different types of customers
how we start with the ones in kenya for
example kenya is a very good market for
us
a family in kenya pays 35 a month on
firewood
and we actually provided a biogas system
for 30 dollars a month and after
two and a half years
they own the device it's theirs
so they save money from the first day
they fit it with the cow manu they have
cows
in their backyard then they feed it with
the commonal
and actually they get enough gas for all
their meals
so actually they save money and they get
clean gas because they suffer from the
smoke from the firewood is creating a
lot of smoke and creating creating
respiration diseases
with this is one type of customer other
type is a
like in the u.s we have thousands of
families that actually they have the
goal
to reach to a point that they are
self-sustained that they have a
self-sustained house
that is providing its own energy
treating its own ways we want to reduce
the footprint
it's a growing community a growing
community there is a lot of
knowledge tribes trying to between them
and we are giving them the best solution
how to treat organic waste
other communities are off-breeders
off-breeders are
many in the u.s they live in in
a in a place where they'll not connect
to the grid of electricity or not
connecting to the grid of sewage and
they need solution to treat their human
waste their
and their food waste and we have
provided them solution
the future where we are heading now
is for example for a multi-family house
so you have a the same mechanism that
you have today either you throw the
waste through a kitchen grinder
or through the the chute will throw the
waste today
and the system will take it
directly from the kitchen grinder to the
bioga system and the burger system will
create energy that will heat the water
for the whole
multi-family house we have already few
uh systems like that which ends this is
the next stage of hombage we are
adjusting those solutions to restaurants
for example
in in in those scenarios we are actually
providing a better way a more
user-friendly way
to throw the waste so it will be easier
for the normal user than take the waste
outside to the garbage
so i have to say oh sheik at this point
i'm sold it sounds perfect it sounds
like it's economically it's economical
it's easy to implement the consumer side
of it is very friendly
so what's the barrier to having this in
every in every house in the world i mean
there must be some some challenge some
reason why uh this is a little bit
difficult to scale or this is
challenging and
what are the different things that
you're grappling with
leading this endeavor that that make it
a little bit challenging to to push
to to have to be a market leader here
well it's a process it's a journey it
took us years to achieve our goals in
developing countries to create the
distribution channels to get to the
right product the right price
now we are doing it a we are now on the
stage of a
a
well behind prototype and proof of
concept and we actually now in the stage
of better site
meta side is where we are putting those
system
to strategic customers
and we learn
and see that it's going well
next year it would
go to the next stage to
commercial stage and then you will start
to see it
a more and more
in this julie there are many obstacles
it can be awareness regulation a
competition with a normal
waste management stream
so it's a journey and
we are working
we are working there and and going ahead
so tell me a little bit about awareness
how do you how do you do market
education
in a world like this you're changing a
century-old behavior how do you get
people to understand that while they
were used to doing x now they're going
to do why how how do you go about this
yeah
so actually
you know a we are now in time like 10
years ago when we started
we were considered like widows three her
girls
no one understood what we are really
doing
i think today we are more like heroes
because what happened
is the awareness for climate change the
awareness for the crisis that we are
actually
going through now
uh
is is
you know it changed a lot i think last
year was the turning point 2021 was the
turning point
is some of it is because by the
administration
some of it is because the
the
the u.n report which was unbelievable
that you report about climate change
um
made things happen last year and i think
the awareness went high when went up
now
there is new regulation for example in
california that the
california vermont that you cannot throw
organic waste that will end up in
landfill it's forbidden to take organic
left to to landfills
uh there is the crisis now in ukraine
putin
that is actually russia is sourcing most
of the gas to europe and to other places
it's actually sponsoring the war
so
i think a lot of things are happening
around us
that are working to raise the awareness
for more sustainable solution
more rain
more sustainable more ecological more
economical solution and and
and we are there so our efforts i'm
speaking with you i'm speaking with the
students we are doing marketing we'll
we're doing a lot of
work to raise the awareness not just for
our solution but
to put a focus on the problem
and yeah
there is a lot a lot more to be done
right and and i think that it's
important to understand this is a years
of journey right this is not a an
overnight idea it's not that you came
and said overnight okay now we have this
new system it's perfect and we're going
there's a lot of r b here it's a long
journey
i love how you're starting with the
underdeveloped areas and you're creating
what sounded to me when you were talking
about the 35 a month for the firewood
and the 30 a month for the home bio gas
mechanism you're not just going and as a
what what a decade ago people would call
tree hugger going and preaching to
somebody to to to worsen their own
condition for the sake of the world
which probably in a utilitarian point of
view is is the right thing to do on a
global scale but
you're actually finding innovative
research driven solutions that are
making it a real necessity for people to
want to to do this right because you're
actually saving the money you're making
it more economical and and i love the
perspective of the journey that you're
on to to at the end bring this to every
house in the world multi multi-family
house it's a it's a really
awesome journey and i urge anybody to go
into your website
the product looks so cool and you have
all these different case studies there
of the different people in different
countries of how they use it so i think
that's that it's such a valuable mission
and definitely an inspiration for me for
why you do what you do so oshik thank
you very very much this was a pleasure
best of luck with home biogas best of
luck with the remainder of the journey
and i look forward to seeing it in my
own home thank you very much for hosting
me
[Music]